[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain an american science fiction
film called planet of the apes 2001.
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 2029. captain leo davidson is an
astronaut aboard the united states air
force space station oberon he and his
team are with apes who are specially
trained for space missions at the
beginning of the movie we are introduced
to one of such chimpanzees named
pericles he works closely with the
captain and is very good at his job leo
receives a video message from his
friends on earth but while watching it
the lights go out and the electronic
devices start to malfunction the
flickering of the lights causes the
animals aboard to panic leo is asked to
report to the bridge to discuss the
malfunction he is then informed about an
electromagnetic storm approaching the
space station the standard procedure is
to send an ape to take initial radiation
and gamma-ray readings and make sure the
storm is safe for a human astronaut to
approach
leo superior asks him to get pericles
ready for the trip leo retaliates and
claims that it is his job as a captain
to report the initial readings but
everyone else asks him to follow the
standard procedure why this literal
astronaut captain is willing to throw
his life away for a monkey is anyone's
best guess he then prepares pericles for
the mission the creature is seated in a
small pod that he pilots to the storm
only some minutes after the takeoff the
scientists notice that the pod is off
course and pericles heart rate is rising
eventually they lose track of the pod
and declare that it is lost
leo sneaks into a pod and launches into
space to get the chimp even though his
superiors ask him to return he gets a
visual of the pod that pericles is in
but before he can report it his pod
crashes into a massive foreign object
after the impact he loses all signal
from the space station he crashes yet
again this time into a bright wormhole
the pod malfunctions and crashes into a
planet's surface that looks a lot like
the earth leo lands on a water body and
somehow survives the crash he walks
around exploring the forest he is in the
first person he meets is a man who seems
to be a native of the jungle the man and
a group behind him are running away from
wild apes who are chasing them without
thinking much about it leo also begins
to run with them the apes wear armor for
protection and seem to be more advanced
than humans they abduct most of the
group as the surviving ones try to run
away all of them including leo are
eventually enslaved and taken away in a
human-run carriage they reach a
civilization of humanoid apes where
humans are used for household work and
entertainment and the apes run the
society the ape children throw stones at
the captured humans calling them dirty
we are introduced to a female ape arie
who supports human rights and protests
the way they are treated in society she
scolds the kids and tells them to
respect all beings damn these monkeys
are pc the slaves are then sold to a
dealer after they are put into the cages
a little ape child buys a human girl to
keep her as a pet the adults are dragged
out and marked with a hot iron stick
arie intervenes and asks the dealer to
be less ruthless to humans because they
also have rights leo takes this
opportunity to grab the iron rod and
hold her hostage he whispers to her to
help him escape this place a human girl
named dinah also tries to run away but
is caught by the dealer he claims that
he will have to put down both leo and
dinah to save their lives aery asks the
dealer to sell them to her the dealer is
reluctant at first but agrees anyway
aerys father is a well-respected senator
who doesn't like that area has brought
two wild humans into his house he asks
her to keep them in check because he
will soon have guests over one of the
guests is general thade a sadistic
chimpanzee military commander who wants
full control over the ape civilization
when leo and dinah are alone in the
kitchen he asks her how the monkeys
managed to get more powerful than humans
dinah claims that they have always been
that way leo is then taken outside to
serve the guests as the guests engage in
conversation leo overhears fade saying
that humans outnumber apes by a large
number arie puts forward her ideas of
equality between humans and apes but
fade claims that her principles threaten
the apes prosperity when leo comes to
serve the table thade forcefully opens
his mouth and mocks him arie leaves the
table at the site and thade follows her
it turns out that he has been asking her
to marry him for quite some time but
because of his cold soul she refuses you
would think that he would want her dead
because of their polar opposite
viewpoints but drama i guess
after dinner leo and dinah are locked
inside a cage with the house slaves at
night leo manages to open the cage and
run away with dinah and the other humans
dinah insists that she won't run away
without her family who is still locked
up in the dealership they run to the
said dealership and free her father and
the other human slaves following that
the group makes their way to the forest
soon the soldiers are ordered to look
for the escaped prisoners the murderous
general thade and his junior colonel
attar march ape warriors to pursue the
humans while trying to run away the
group bumps into arie who agrees to help
them at leo's request however before
they can escape through a tunnel colonel
attar approaches them dinah's father who
is already very injured runs to fight
the ape and distract him he sacrifices
his life in the fight but because of him
the others run away safely leo takes
them to the lake that he had landed in
we find out that the apes are terrified
of water because they cannot swim leo
and dinah swim into the lake and
retrieve a bag from the crashed pod it
contains a gun and a beacon that leo
uses to send a signal to the space
station he receives data that says that
the space station is already in the
atmosphere most probably looking for him
just then the dealer limbo attacks them
and tries to abduct one of the humans
leo threatens him with the gun and holds
him hostage because if they let him go
he will lead the others to the group
after that they continue to follow the
signal received by the beacon to help
leo go back home meanwhile back in the
town thade asks the senator for absolute
power to eradicate the humans he wants
to take the opportunity to expand his
power and eventually rule the world of
apes the senator believes that his
daughter was abducted by the humans so
he does as they'd says and provides him
with full authority thade's father gets
severely sick so he is called to meet
him in his place general crawl goes to
stop the humans thade's father is the
only man he trusts and respects the old
ape knows something that the younger
generation doesn't thade asked his
father about the source of his knowledge
the father ape then tells him about the
first of their kind named the semos
before the arrival of cmos the apes were
the slaves to humans who ruled society
fade believes it to be impossible but
his father continues the explanation he
reveals a hidden old gun and says that
humans possess the power of invention
and technology which is greater than
their strength the old ape begs his son
to not let the humans get to a place
called the kalima it is the holy temple
of cmos that holds the secret of their
true origin if the humans find out about
it they will retaliate and destroy the
apes world in the meantime the group of
escapees makes their way to the kalima
where leo believes his team is waiting
for him as they get closer they see
scarecrows made to keep the apes and the
humans away from the holy temple they
finally get to a checkpoint where camps
of apes have been settled to guard the
way to the temple general crawl also
arrives there and takes command of the
troops when the sun sets leo creates a
distraction using his gun and makes his
way to the camp on horseback he and the
group managed to set the camp on fire
and cross the river which is the only
obstacle between them and the temple of
cmos a while later fate arrives at the
camp and is furious at the troops for
not being able to stop the humans he
gathers them all and sets off to look
for the enemies from the other side of
the mountain the escapees on the other
hand rest for the night and reach the
seemos's temple the next day leo is
beyond surprised when he sees that the
temple is actually the space station
oberon that he left a few days ago arie
claims that it is impossible because the
temple has been there for thousands of
years since the station is powered by
nuclear energy leo is able to retrieve
visual logs to see what actually
happened to his ship then he finds out
that when he entered the wormhole he
jumped through time and reached the year
5021 the oberon remained in the year
2029 and looked for him they were never
able to find him and the station
eventually crashed to this planet's
surface in 2029 the apes that were
aboard the oberon went wild and started
to attack the crew members but
eventually one of the apes named cmos
stopped them and led the way as time
passed the apes took over and the people
leo is with currently are the
descendants of his own fellow crew
members now he has no way to return home
when he steps out of the ruins of the
oberon several humans surround him they
have heard the story about the brave
human and want to help him fight the
apes but leo knows that they will not be
able to win against thousands of apes
who are coming for them he asks them to
run away but they stay put in their
decision then he thinks of an idea since
the oberon has plenty of nuclear fuel he
plans to use it to fire a final blast at
the apes when they arrive he makes all
the humans hide behind the spaceship and
uses the escapees as bait to invite the
apes when the first batch of apes is
close enough the nuclear blast sends
them flying however soon after thade and
the second batch of the army attack them
they begin to overpower the humans with
their strength leo and thade get into a
fierce battle but stop when they notice
a familiar ship landing from the sky it
contains pericles who had also been lost
in the wormhole it turns out the
electromagnetic storm actually releases
people from it in an opposite direction
in time with their entrance which
explains why pericles arrived a few days
after leo convenient science is
convenient the apes then bow
interpreting his arrival as the return
of cmos and hostilities between humans
and apes suddenly cease ignoring
everyone pericles runs into the remains
of the oberon and leo runs after him
followed by general thade thade wants to
end pericles to attain absolute power
but leo stops him the two get into a
fight leo's gun lands inside the pilot's
deck during the struggle fade goes
inside to retrieve it but is trapped
when leo locks the automatic door the
enraged ape fires the gun repeatedly at
the door but the ricochets create sparks
that scare him he hides under a control
panel accepting his defeat deciding to
return to earth leo gives pericles to
arie who promises to look after him he
tells everyone that humans and apes are
supposed to live in peace and harmony it
was simos's wish all along after saying
farewell to arie and dinah leo climbs
aboard pericles's undamaged pod and
travels back in time through the same
electromagnetic storm and crashes in
washington dc on earth he looks up at
what appears to be the lincoln memorial
only to find that it is now a monument
memorializing general thade a swarm of
police officers firefighters and news
reporters all of whom are apes descend
upon him now for the explanation of the
ending we can assume that leo has
entered into the future because of the
electromagnetic storm it is likely that
after leo's departure from the previous
planet thade somehow managed to break
free and traveled to earth through the
same electromagnetic storm he was then
released to earth thousands of years
before leo's arrival because the ape was
kicked off of his planet he managed to
rule the earth and overthrow the humans
and now everyone on earth is an ape
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching